for climate campaigners BP is a pariah
it's art sponsorships make institutions
like the British Museum a target for
protesters now it's set landmark targets
of its own committing BP to be carbon
neutral for all the oil and gas it
produces and to cut the carbon intensity
of half of everything it sells by 2050
it's a striking first step for their new
chief executive Bernard Looney a
lifelong oil man promising to transform
the energy giant just two weeks into the
job I get it
the world does have a carbon budget it
is finite and it is running out fast and
we need a rapid transition to Net Zero
BP is prized by investors for the
dividends it pays more than 8 billion
pounds last year but mr. Looney says
this will not be a choice between the
planet and our pensions you talk about
the priorities of the people you speak
to but personally which number matters
more to you hitting these carbon targets
or the dividend it's a great question to
ask it's also an easy question to answer
they're all important and in many ways
they serve each other we have to be
financially strong because that is how
we will make that transition climate
activists and campaigners welcome BP's
commitments but warned they may be too
little too late they're recognizing
we've got a window in which we can act
to protect and defend life on Earth
however Zero Carbon by 2050 is planning
for disaster and and it's a disaster in
which we lose everything
that would reach arish BP has spent the
last decade trying to recover its
reputation from the Deepwater Horizon
oil spill and investors say they can no
longer afford to ignore climate concerns
the top priority of our planners is that
investment is made with purpose
and that it makes a build a better world
rather than doing the exact opposite to
actually create climate change BP will
still be pumping oil and gas in 30 years
time and these targets will not address
the climate crisis alone but a company
that currently can't give its money away
in sponsorships may prove a model for
others
Paul Kelso sky news